how's it goin bro my name is Priyanka
welcome back to the moon
hallelujah let's go to the lighthouse
like we said in the last episode there
it looks really small compared - when
you turn it up
Ted staff took it going oh yeah I forgot
my parachute ah silly kids you don't
need a parachute somebody to go south to
go to it well son of a barrel I didn't
know that then we come from South Oh No
I I'm okay we're fine
they're fine this does not feel like the
correct way damn it Oh No my number two
[ __ ] but someone broke oh I don't know
who did that oh don't wait doctor
allowing I'll even buy another no don't
do it
she will oh yeah sure just ask her
afterwards well we can't you need to get
going now though poor little Timmy it's
poor little beach ball
we took the [ __ ] out of that thing
though all right yeah yeah yeah I got
this it's over here what it's uh it's
smoking
what's that dummy did crash the car that
was a rustling yeah
Oh dr. Rosen Lane hisses you know yet I
have no idea had to say that all right
yes we're going north
oh there's so annoying a square well I
scrub hey let's make it up
[ __ ] him up ah [ __ ] but don't worry cats
I got just a tacit with tornado punch
loudest yes and stop it or with a my
Yamaha yeah she call the cops on a come
on I wasn't actually got it don't you
like your Oakley oh that's good
we're against violence here you should
have be ashamed of yourself
let's name it DD okay let this go my
whole night is ruined
huh what do you want bird what you want
all right
this game is full of surprises I tell
you that what the hell all right let's
go to the lighthouse already
all right and there we are
finally
[Music]
all right we're going let's go to the
lighthouse and find some paper bunnies I
don't know I guess that's all we're
doing wait wait what's up with I wear
this in memory of river a wild river
wild huh Welsh was chief Johnny's wife
come on hmm all right I guess we go
click it please thank you spooky
not even controlling this that's okay I
don't really want to walk up those
stairs anyway oh here they are the paper
bunnies isn't it why does he like to
make paper bunnies I don't understand
freakin old people old geezers seems
like there's a thing haven't been
functioning for a while now let's grab
this it's a multi colored paper rabbit
hey Mitch it wasn't even last week
oh yeah Johnny but you came here before
he fell ill again two colors huh
am I the only one who's a little creeped
out by these yeah no yeah you are yep
what that someone's calling me back I
should have guessed out yeah yeah what
coming blah blah stupid Rosalind alright
let's head back as for this
I received a paper rabbit we're doing
good breaths and we don't even have to
go walk back where we'll tell apart love
teleported it's the best thing ever
what are they doing I'm looking at what
a cactus where you're doing hello as she
talks burning ads with my magnifying
glass using moonlight okay I was taking
a nap then god it's so hard to be a
smartass now you're pretty good at being
half of it
oh [ __ ] me yeah helmets on the couch get
it on we're going in oh did he change
what it's doing okay I guess I go to my
equipment no I guess I go to the bed
maybe what man what am I supposed to do
let's talk to her go on I'll watch over
his physical condition with what am I
supposed to do okay I guess this is no
that wasn't it by the way I'm curious
how does it work
do you just write him another life like
a No
I want to know actually what no I'm no
novelist we can we can just write an
entire life menu we're way too many
directions then how do you tell it it's
mainly the machine that does the doing
naturally since we aren't paid enough to
get our hands dirty in a nutshell our
job is to travel through his memories to
as early as possible
and when we do we could then transfer
Israelis desire of going to the moon to
the reconstruction of the world and
himself at that early site and with the
help of wiki of his dad ozone the
machine would then simulate a rerun
accepted time will have the motivation
of his red already server that is how
fun so you'll be depending on him
fulfilling his own wish by simply having
the desire to how could that be
everyone has ambition for things but
most don't accomplish them that's
because in the real was ambitious and
fluctuate and fade people start things
with a passion but eventually they lose
that initial drive and slow down it's
true that's true but imagine if you were
locked into that initial push throughout
your entire life never wavering it's
more powerful than it seems
I'd pay that being said no ambition is
gonna help a dead man you better get to
go get started oh of course
sorry alright I still don't really know
what I'm supposed to do your helmets on
the couch alright where's couch here
alright I guess there's no reason to
prolong this all right here we go
I'm really curious what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen
fifth you had me in the noting screen oh
sorry
well it's gone well now I don't know
what I feel about this huh all right
this should be the last accessible
memory the same at a speech for all
except Johnny dumb let's get'em at any
time you will view your position in time
by moving the mouse to worry the toddler
okay I didn't read that right but I
understood it somebody to go back in
time we going went back in time back in
time maybe we should go to like where he
used to be in the White House and we
can't go anywhere we can go out though I
can only guess that we're going to the
lighthouse I hope I'm not wrong though
well it's different now we can't go
everywhere to the right maybe no I
really are we going back in time err
Oh lighthouse what is this
some beautiful music in this game what
is that
maybe that his wife Johnny
[Music]
what a pleasant surprise
we don't get many visitors Ronnie my
name is dr. ivara Celine and this is dr.
von Matterhorn dr. Lorenzo fun so
annoying dr. Neil what are you familiar
with a Sigmund Agency of life generation
are you or are you two from the agency
how convenient
I've just been thinking of calling you
it's not a coincidence because we went
back in time I guess
Lily Garret should be pleased well
a-actually you already call this ah oh
no what did he do alright Oh like there
we're here to fulfill your our contract
from the relative future careful there
if you slip of the cliff ah
Cavalieri asleep you're glad we're gonna
have real out of this memory watch it
Neal show some respect
is this program you know I know but this
is his last accessible memory and we
need its cooperation watch come right we
can't just reboot it why would you waste
time like that hero
[Music]
you are here to take me to the moon
aren't ya
yes John I like everybody's now bad
actually I suppose I had a good run not
enough it seems Ducks do chill don't be
so rude all time so can you do it can
you take me to the moon we can't but you
might be able to why don't you want to
go why do you want to go there
I don't know oh we need to go daigo dig
deeper that's fine you can tell us it's
essential for helping us to to get you
to go there do you want the fame the
money you gotta have a motive I'm sorry
I I really don't know I just I do I can
already tell that isn't gonna be a pain
in the ass never that's Johnny here's
what we'll do we need to get to your
childhood but it's too distant to do so
in one memory hop thus we will need to
traverse through your memories with a
gradual all right we need to go through
all these steps I guess backward leaps
which you've given us permission to do
in relative future once we lay down the
way poncing channel members for direct
access will be returned here that's when
you will need to help us influence the
childhood you to become an astronaut or
to get on a giant catapult the point is
you let have to have more to say than
just I don't know as long as you can
take me to the moon I will cooperate in
any way possible
good it's getting interesting now in
order to leap in memory we need an item
that is important on you do you have a
mement or some sort of us to get started
let's see what he got it's a book I can
guess ash but already have that thing
that will do well shall we ladies first
[Music]
we just click on it we'll need to
prepare this movement of us alright do
nothing Oh
all right I did it oh okay click on the
orb to filled pieces this is a puzzle
don't worry breasts I'm a genius
[Music]
that did not work okay I got it
there we go there we go
nailed it the vendor can now be acted it
for traversal traversal wait what about
my privacy don't make me laugh well try
to violate what we can't avoid but in
most cases it can't be helped I wouldn't
want to want people going my brains
that's creepy
but it's a good way to tell a story so
let's just that is creepy he really
likes those [ __ ] bunnies and that sie
doch that's brown for whatever reason
yeah it's a sign yeah going back in
cameras
we didn't go back much did we I really
know turn off visibility and interact
direct ability and they'll be messy to
be seen
yeah yeah you're happy that that dad oh
geez I forgot my ask him about all these
rabbits this is creepy yeah we probably
should have checked this record for
psychopath II first what what did he
hear me
that's impossible it's probably this
part of his memory this is kind of
creepy
what then I stand my point
anyway quit blabbering and fight a
moment here to hop from interact with
these objects to establish five memory
links alright let's start with oh I
didn't mean to go up
okay let's start upstairs son
all right we got a backpack and all
patched but what is this
Amelia Mexico I guess we'll find out
okay we got one fresh flowers all right
got to don't if I have explained our
presence to him and every memory I'll go
crazy
don't ten all right I guess I was it up
here oh maybe this a glass bottle of
picked olives okay I hate this stuff
what the hay is picked pick it all
exactly
all right that's apparently a valid
memory I don't really know why I would I
need to shake everything here oh that
was one thing - all right
I think the umbrella is the last piece
let me go down and get that lets get
that what it took away one oh we add it
to that oh oh oh I get it but did we did
we
[Music]
while our G special having two colors
when our siblings looks around and [ __ ]
what's that you think you're really
creepy why yes I agree that's totally me
maybe it's this thing not really that
difficult but whatever all right this
watch we can click the watch all right
there we go that was to watch let's go
back in time ha
what that [ __ ] was that what that it
that's it I'm doing the break all right
you can travel with an umbrella
all right that's kind of weird but let's
do it yep there corner orb can flip the
entire diagonal all right so it's gonna
be a more advanced puzzle I guess did I
do it yes I did
J yeah yes you can you can give me my
Nobel Prize later I know I'm pretty yeah
mmm I probably thought that faster than
I didn't I'm sorry I'm just kidding
all right let's go back in time breaths
what are we now up if not where's it's
still an old why it comes rain through
is it better than unto I don't mind it
regardless
seems like this memory hops only span a
short period of time we need to find a
laughing memento or it's going to take
forever man just enjoy the scenery
alright what do we talk to him in memory
of river II miles oh ok so we just go
through and look at his stuff a stuffed
toy platypus honestly I just don't think
this animal has the right fix that's the
world that big enough for you to that's
true
alright we can go inside now for
whatever reason it's Finnish River
what's finished Jon like you I'll be
able to watch over her every day she
won't be alone anymore I might never
understand why but they stayed true to
your wish I'm sure Anya is grateful to
you too
[Music]
but whenever I'm gone I guess their
child dying that's kind of sad who is
going to watch over us it's chill
[Music]
who are you my name is Eva I was just
passing by was she your wife yes
her name was River that's a special name
I I didn't eat it didn't need to happen
hmm she she didn't need to do it but she
you wouldn't understand I don't even
understand
[Music]
it's fearful skin is beautiful you can't
say anything else well you can I guess
opinions alright we're almost back in
time almost back in time but on that
note I will have to end this episode
here but like a previous you enjoyed
Bruce and want to see more of this I'm
enjoying this a lot more than I expected
I don't think it's really interesting
subscribe remember today and I'll see
you next episode Bruce say awesome so
stop taking the ketchup acting song are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me